we're gonna make it we didn't finish our
journey it's gotta be more to this ah
holy [ __ ] what's the mom mama Eagle six
of them
it's gone mama Eagles
nice unibrow
it looks like chess pieces
is that US that's us where's me
I'm alive
they're saving me
I got my scarf back [ __ ] yeah
oh it's on now that's banked my scarf
isn't that long whoa
holy [ __ ] I'm controlling this my god
dragons dragons I'm scared ah we're
going holy [ __ ] this is epic
my [ __ ] god I got goose bumps 9000
oh [ __ ] 9001 wah
dragon carpet dragons oh my god this is
[ __ ] epic huh is that who I think it
is huh
bang you made it my man I'm so happy oh
my God we're alive I didn't think you'd
make it my friend I didn't think you had
it in ya
just kidding I know you had it in ya I'm
flying to peller's and [ __ ] oh this is
[ __ ] epic god damn this game is
[ __ ] epic jesus [ __ ] that sorry
I'm sweating so much
Jason's just different that's there
I'm flying dragons now I don't even give
a [ __ ] what are we going out through
that moon it's skateboarding time you're
chess I'm a carrot face okay I can pick
this coming my scarf is so long do you
see this if you don't think this is
fashionable backflip 360 Oh
god
I have no idea what's gonna have that
next that's a good game right there all
right we got to fly up the tentacles
thank I'm not really good at signing up
tentacles I don't know if I ever told
you it's not my thing all right I feel
weird it feels pornographic okay
okay we're still flying up them
so going it's really if I if you have if
you ever like why I imagined it'd be
something like this you know oh my god
so beautiful I was a close call bank
over up at the where up at the friggin
top we're going to the top bank we're
going to the [ __ ] talk gorgeous yes
oh no oh I [ __ ] nearly missed it all
there's dragons and started this is love
it's love right
how do we go ahead
I'm trying we're going up the waterfall
I'm riding the dragon
I'm taking this shortcut until they fit
I don't even know where Bank this
oh sure
now I
4j
oh boy yeah seriously
probably the most beautiful game I am
but it says I don't know where to go
because I lost bang
I was that Bank tell me why
maybe I need to wait for him here maybe
bank laws
I never actually got long something
and it's got so caught up in it
oh I gotta go up there that is the that
is said after that we're done I could
just fly here
I'm flying through the mountain pounds
we're doing with that I'm doing it I'm
doing it for your bank episode for you
a where's Ben
we're going we're going our journey ends
here attending
mom
god
banked
Stefano was they now walking towards the
light
I don't even know what's gonna happen
and I'm almost there and it's so bright
I can't see anything
and throw
I made a throw
I saw one of that I think is that you
banked there's something else there I
can't say I can't say anything I want to
say
was there someone out there
huh what is this I was worried it was
gonna be over
ah
Oh what's happening
my god I'm going to disguise but I came
from the skies as well maybe we used it
to escape to another world and we let
this one go thank you for playing
journey
created by that game company that one
but that one of them
I don't know about the ending let me
know your take on it oh we're making
everything better
is that it we've defrosting it
maybe this story is still going on here
and I'm not even realizing
because that's us right that's us flying
through the entire journey back again
I know that's all that's what I think
like the Dragons came and we had to
abandon the place and then we fly away
through the mountains
but I don't know
I usually I'm usually wrong with these
things so let me let me know in the
comments and I'd be interested
it seems like a typical game where
there's no right and wrong in your take
on it I hate when people say oh this is
how it is it's nothing else I don't
think that's why what the creator's
intended
I don't know
is underwater levels
I hope the song is in copyrighted I
don't think it is I like to show the
credits on a game like this at least I
usually do it this one is deserved this
serves every second of it
saving alright I guess I guess that's it
then
oh this is where we slide slide I have
to say really if you're thinking about
playing this game I highly recommend
experienced and fully taking in the
atmosphere by yourself if you have a
Playstation
it's a PlayStation 3 exclusive it was
150 crowns which is probably like 15
bucks 20 bucks maybe I don't know so
it's well worth your pocket I hate on
people say like some people seem to
think like a game has to have a lot of
gameplay hours in it otherwise you don't
want to waste money on it
but I'll take quality over quantity and
quantity being how much time you play
any day any day I love games like this
that don't feel dragged out and they
don't fit maybe a little bit the wind
honestly the end but other than that no
I loved everything
I don't know it's hard to it's hard to
summarize I don't know
I
Oh
I think it was what law many people
working on this
than in the game after all
fire-engine I can't wait to see what
other games they have made and check
them out and I know a lot of us suggest
it'll calm me to me it's a game that I
played a little bit when I was I don't
know how old it is but that could be
something else to play and a lot of you
bros momentum you to play it and it's
kind of similar in in the terms of these
games with Shadow Ball Colossus and
journey and all these kind of stuff so
if you're interested in it I would love
to play it but I'm not gonna play
something that people aren't interested
in me playing I'll just play it by
myself that instead yeah but I had a
blast playing through this with you
thank you so much for watching with me I
hope you still got a good feeling if you
felt as excited half excited as I was
when I played it I'm pretty sure you
enjoyed it at least
what a fantastic game I feel I feel so
happy and after playing this I don't
know it's crazy I just loved it all the
way through and there we are back with a
loading screen all right very
interesting very interesting indeed
anyway like a pro division joyed
subscribe come over today and I'll see
you next episode of a bar make happy
birth stay awesome
what the [ __ ]
Oh